unfortunately my experience in high
school was
um you know not the best because i had
to race again
biological males my entire high school i
lost a lot of
opportunities because i lost four state
championships
to all new england awards and countless
other opportunities to place
in advance and medal
i'm dave rubin and we're going to be
doing something a bit different today
let me give you a little back
here on may 22nd of this year usa today
put out an
op-ed from collegiate track star chelsea
mitchell
about her experiences competing against
transgender
athletes however on may 25th just three
days later the publication
changed the word male to transgender
throughout her piece without warning and
called her out for using quote
hurtful language in an editor's note the
outlet explained that the
op-ed was updated to quote reflect
usa today's standards and style
guidelines
we regret that hurtful language was used
today i'm speaking with the author of
that op-ed and her lawyer
please welcome one of the fastest girls
in connecticut
track star chelsea mitchell and her
lawyer who is the general counsel
at the alliance defending freedom
kristin wagoner
ladies welcome to the reuben report
thank you
thank you all right so i'm glad to have
both of you
uh kristen i reached out to you
originally when i saw this
story on twitter because it just so fit
so many of the things
that i've been talking about on this
show
chelsea i'll i'll start with you since
you wrote the original piece
um well i guess first just tell me how
you got into track and
and and you enjoy running right like
that's really what this is all about you
want to compete against girls
and running yeah i was an athlete
my entire life when i got to high school
i started running track
um and i kind of quickly realized that i
was really good at it and
unfortunately my experience in high
school was
um you know not the best because i had
to race again
biological males my entire high school i
lost a lot of
opportunities because i lost four state
championships
two all new england awards and countless
other opportunities to place in advance
and meddle right so when did it start
that biological boys
trans girls were in the races that you
were in
in girls races yeah my freshman year was
when
it first started happening and and was
it immediate that they were all
like right out of the gate they were
faster and and winning all the races
um right out of the gate but we're still
racing very high in the state i was
when i was a freshman i placed seventh
at the state open in the hundred meters
and um one of the biological males was
third
knocking me out of the spot to advance
the new england championship
right so so what caused you to write
this piece and then i'll get to sort of
where the the legal part of this is then
we'll get kristen involved
i really just wanted to bring attention
to what has been happening in
connecticut because
i personally think it's really unfair to
have biological norms
against biological females because we
just cannot keep up with the physical
advance of a male body
um and so i decided to put out my own
story out there so that people could
understand what was happening and how
unfair it was
and to be clear i'm guessing you are not
anti-trans in any way
no put it out there okay so so kristin
when
did you get involved in all of this
well initially we filed a complaint with
the department of education that was
during the trump administration in june
of 2019
and as time continued to pass and we
weren't seeing
the department of ed take substantive
action on it
we ended up filing a lawsuit in february
of 2020
and that was chelsea's senior year and
there were some circumstances for her
where she was ready to
move forward with that and we were glad
to assist because
there were four state championship
titles that she was losing
and it was just coming to the end where
we needed to get judicial relief and so
that's why we filed the lawsuit
right so chelsea what do most people
think
sort of behind the scenes i sense that
there's sort of an activist class and a
a media class
that loves pushing these stories but the
average person that's going to these
track events and watching you lose to a
biological male
probably gets why you're upset about
this
yeah i think a lot of people who have
seen this happen in connecticut
understand how unfair this is basically
because
these biological males were feeding us
females by
significant margins in these races and
it was happening at every
every single race that we raced against
when we were losing and it was
a big difference yeah
so so kristin what what do you want
legally what would be right
for to legally happen at this point
well there are four girls that are in
the case in connecticut two have
graduated and two remain in the
connecticut schools and so for the two
that have graduated
including chelsea and also selena sol
those records need to be corrected
in this case alone it's important to
realize there were two boys that
identified as girls
one of those boys competed as a girl
three weeks before
he decided to move over and compete as a
girl and those two boys took
15 different races championships away
from girls during those three seasons
so there was a huge impact in
connecticut so we want the records to be
set straight
and then for the girls that are
continuing in this connecticut system
they need to be assured that they're
going to be biological girls competing
against each other
and that it's going to be a fair playing
field moving forward
i suspect i know the answer to this
question but is there any evidence
of biological girls transitioning
to be boys and then winning in boys
sports
i i none that i can think of i mean i'm
sure there may be isolated cases where
that's true but what we do know is that
when boys transition into the girl
sports
there are hundreds literally hundreds of
high school boys that can beat the most
elite female runners
and they have a 10 to 50 performance gap
so
when you're just looking at averages
alone immediate
mediocre male athlete will almost always
be able to beat
an elite female athlete now chelsea if i
was to repeat what kristen just said
right there somebody would say you're
being transphobic boys and girls men and
women are exactly the same
do you concede that there are some
biological differences
of course there are biological
differences between males and females
that's why we have sex separated sports
i mean
uh you know it's kind of hard for you to
just put biological man in the you know
category and say that
it's
and they would not win the state
championship if they were in the boy
category
right so what would you prefer that that
those trans
athletes do should they have their own
division all together or
you would just prefer that okay you were
born
male you should just be competing with
the with the boys regardless of how you
feel
about yourself something like that i
think the most important thing right now
is to protect the female category and
make sure
that us females are having a fair
competition and i think that should be
the number one priority
right kristen what do you make of usa
today switching some of the
language here i mean once you submit an
op-ed you know
you know chelsea wrote a piece that was
honest and heartfelt
and then suddenly it's not just that
they're changing language the
implication is somehow that
what chelsea was saying was somehow
hateful
it was shocking to us i mean we we write
op-eds all the time our clients are
writing op-eds
and we can't think of any other instance
in the 30-year history we've been
involved in public interest law
where they have felt like they could
change what someone else wrote without
even
advanced notice like we didn't get a
call that said hey just want you to know
this just happened and it's just it's
shocking in terms of the lack of
journalistic integrity
and also the accusations because nothing
could be further from the truth
right well is there any is there any
legal recourse you can take with them on
that i mean the idea that they changed
it three days later
implying that somehow the policy changed
as if they didn't read it in the first
place
there probably is but i don't know that
we're as interested in that is making
sure that the public knows
that this language isn't appropriate
that what usa has done
is usa today has done isn't right and
winning this case
for our girls i mean girls should have
equal opportunities the same
opportunities that their brothers have
and they need to be authentic and real
and that can't happen
when male-bodied athletes are competing
in the girls category
chelsea can you just talk a little bit
about what it's like to be a young
person
going through the mob and the and the
monster that so many people
fear that that's really why i reached
out to kristen originally when i saw
this because i just saw oh
here's just a nice girl who wants to run
and tell her story that's it and then of
course you read the stuff that they're
saying about you
and about you kristen and all the rest
of it and it's just it's just
nothing to do with the truth it's really
frustrating especially because
this is just about sports you know
biology matters and sports and i think
that's really obvious to a lot of people
so you know i'm not trying to be harmful
or in any way
um i just want to be able to run on a
but what about getting all the mean
tweets not fun right
no but you know you always gotta look at
the support instead of
all the mean tweets yeah kristen are you
seeing this uh you guys are in
connecticut but are you seeing this like
all across the country there's so many
cases that sound so similar to this
absolutely um we have a case in idaho i
mean as you've probably seen
there have been 30 some different state
proposals that were just proposed this
last year because we are
seeing it happen across the united
states i've seen it on my own daughters
teams in conservative
arizona softball as well as soccer
we've had volleyball teams that have
called us where
literally a girl got a concussion from
being hit with a guy playing and of
course they're playing on the lower nets
right
and then we have the idaho case which um
where the aclu
immediately brought suit challenging a
law that protected women in that state
and they're trying to get it struck down
at the ninth circuit and we represent
two track athletes at
the collegiate level in that case as
well i'm actually glad that you brought
that case up because i was going to
bring that up
what has happened to the aclu that was
once the great defender
of civil liberties in the united states
and now is is
actually attacking women in essence
it's horrific i mean it's just so
stunning when you think about the fact
that the aclu would go after
you know would defend those in skokie so
many years ago
and yet on free speech matters they
don't believe in free speech anymore
and we used to be able to say that you
know we would defend
to the death you for your free speech
rights even if we disagreed with you and
that used to be the aclu's position
but they've abandoned it long ago in
favor of ideology
i will say though that there is a a
broader coalition that's supporting
chelsea
and this issue there are you know
feminists that are coming out and saying
this is not right
and we're thankful for them we might not
align with them on other issues
but man where we do align is that
biology matters and that we're setting
women back
by allowing men to call themselves women
and compete against women in their own
categories
chelsea i can sense your you're wired
sort of cool which i like here but can
you talk a little bit about like
what it's like to just be a young person
in this like bizarrely
polarized political time and all of this
stuff you know transgender athletes in
critical race through all of these
things that i'm sure your friends are
talking about
and it's got to be just like a rough
time to be in high school in college
right now
it's definitely hard especially on this
topic because
you know i really believe that you know
biological congressional fairness and
sports and
you know an issue that should be pretty
clear and pretty obvious
has been very politicized and it's
definitely very frustrating to
have it be that way when i don't think
yeah kristin is that the bizarre part
that this doesn't feel like the type of
thing you should even be having to
deal with as a case at some level like
like 15 years ago this never would have
probably got to your desk
no it wouldn't have i mean there are so
many conversations that we have
you know among our 70 attorneys it's
like i can't believe we have to go in
and argue about body parts in the
courtroom
and say that they matter or or that
someone would say that saying a
biological male
is biological male is harmful or hurtful
speech
and this is just common sense and the
science does support it
so we believe that in the end it's an
important issue for the protection of
our women
and our daughters and it's those it's
the female
athletes and women that are going to
suffer the brunt of this harm if we lose
these biological differences in the law
yeah has that been the weird part for
both of you guys that you know the side
that
keeps saying science matters is actually
being quite anti-science right now that
that must be strange for you chelsea
yeah it's definitely frustrating to hear
them kind of
um you know not acknowledge the science
behind biology
yeah uh well how can we how can we shed
further light on this how can we help
you guys chelsea where can i direct
people to if they want to support you
support the cause um you know i just
think
spreading awareness about this issue and
having conversations about it is
definitely
um good you know we want people to
understand what's really happening and
that this is an unfair situation
yeah all right kristen we're going to
direct the people to you that's probably
a better idea we'll we'll link to your
twitter down below but for people that
want to get involved because i know
there's a lot of people they want to
donate to the right causes you know they
they
used to maybe donate to the aclu but
they don't want to anymore they want to
help the lawyers that are on the front
lines of this what can people do
well certainly we all of our services to
our clients are pro bono and we would
appreciate the support we've been
leading on the issue in terms of the
litigation but also
the legislative work we've been in all
of these states and eight states have
passed bills so far
so that's one thing but i want to really
encourage
grassroots support in your own backyard
i mean these things are happening in our
school boards
the same philosophy as you already
linked it with crt
we need to be active when these kinds of
policies are passed because they pass
them under the dark of night
and we need to be adept to those and
have the courage to speak out in our own
communities
and also to be looking out for those
like chelsea who are caught in the
crosshairs
give them words of encouragement because
they feel isolated and they are attacked
and so
those words of encouragement are really
helpful too well chelsea
you're brave you're doing the right
thing and if you ever make it out to la
and you want to run a race with a 44
year old guy with a torn acl in his left
knee
i i could give it a go it probably will
not end well for me
thank you uh kristen we'll we'll link to
some of your stuff down below so people
can
can find out more about the law firm and
what you guys are doing and i thank you
guys for taking the time and oh well i
guess i should ask one other question
which is
um i assume you tried to contact the usa
usa today and say guys this is not cool
what did they say did they even get back
to you we did have a conversation i
didn't have that conversation but our
media team did and as you can see it's
still up
so they did not fix it um and that's
deeply deeply concerning for the future
of journalism
yeah that that's a whole other story
that i cover here pretty much every day
uh well chelsea kristin i thank you guys
and uh
we'll we'll keep watching thank you
thank you
all right take care if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about women's issues
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our women's issues playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell